everybody it's Peter Brown here with a  gamespot news update today it's all  about grand theft auto 5 and part two of  the ill-gotten gains update GTA 5 just  got a little bit bigger with its latest  update following ill-gotten gains part 1  part 2 focuses on high-end apparel  vehicles and weapons for players to  enjoy some of these new items include  the porogen t20 one of the fastest cars  in Los Santos solid gold knuckle dusters  and I fruit snap watch in a new radio  station for consoles called the lab  which is previously only available on PC  alongside ill-gotten gains part 2 is a  new GTA 5 title update 1.28 which  includes a long list of fixes  improvements and tweaks for all versions  of the game are these new items enough  to get you back into GTA 5 and you're a  life of crime let us know in the  comments below and stay tuned to  gamespot com for all your video game and  grand theft auto news updates